So to get our outputs in the correct range,
we're going to use the Modulus Operator. And this
is written with a percent sign. It's usually the
Shift 5 on most keyboards. What modulus does is
takes a number and maps it to the range
based on the remainder when you divide that number.
So the way modulo arithmetic works, is like a
clock. So if we think of having a clock with
12 hours, and then arithmetic on the clock is modulo 12. So if we
were to evaluate 14 modulo 12, what that would mean is,
well, if we start from 0, and we make 14 steps, we're
going to 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14. Where we end up is 2. That's the same
as the remainder we would get by dividing 14 by 12. And
that's the result of 14 modulo 12, is 2. So now we're
going to have a few quizzes, to make sure you that understand the
Modulus Operator, as well as the ord and char operators we introduced.